hey guys welcome to a new series in
planet coaster this one's a bit
different from the ones I've made so far
and it's also a bit different from much
of the things that I see being made by
the community at the moment and many of
the series that I see running right now
in that many of the things that I see at
the moment I think are really focused on
very large-scale kind of impressive and
a very massive scenery not large
landscapes very large theming and just
in general either really expensive theme
parks or just plain out into the fantasy
kind of corner what I see quite a lots
with a bigger focus on making you know
interesting sort of scenes and
landscapes instead of focusing on like
the realism aspects of small theme parks
and that is actually exactly what I want
to try with this park I want to try to
make like a small charming family kind
of park probably operated by a family as
well I think some good examples to
compare it with in real life or like
trips trail in Germany or a hunter Park
also in Germany perhaps a bit of silver
dollars city in terms of how it's going
to be some more smaller and rustic
theming and I think chessington
especially in terms of the scale and how
the theming and generals laid out can
work quite well as an example as well
basically what I want to go for is just
a smaller park with no smaller scenery
less of a budget but still a park that
is focused on scenery it's not going to
be a park like Michigan's Adventure or
Six Flags and that it's going to be
focused on the rides I mean I'm still me
and I'm still gonna want to focus on
scenery but it's you know a different
kind of park than what I've been seeing
you know in planet coaster since the
release of the game and it's something
which I am more familiar with actually I
would say from roller coaster Queen 3
experience when compared to no fantasy
projects on a large scale like L Fame so
in that kind of sense it's kind of going
back to my roots and what I like Quanah
lots and it also adds an ex
challenge you might say that it's maybe
a bit easier to go for a smaller and
low-budget theme park but I think
especially with the low amount of
content that there is in the game and
the fact that I haven't seen this been
done before or at least not much it
actually has a pretty good challenge and
personally I want to get like a good
layout and charming atmosphere in
general with this park in and I'm not
really sure how that's going to happen
because well that's actually something
that I think is surprisingly tough to
get right and it definitely isn't as
easy as just making very large detailed
structures to make something look very
impressive now to talk about what I am
building for a second here I wanted to
start off with the entrance of the park
for one I actually wanted to build a
custom entrance because I do want to get
all of the realistic touches of a theme
park in here and since the original
entrance of planet coaster is just a
premade entrance that you can't really
do anything about but it also doesn't
look as realistic there are no ticket
booths and there are no turnstiles or
anything of that nature I wanted to make
my own small entrance not to mention
that this is going to be a small rustic
park kind of like trips real and all the
things that I've mentioned so I wanted
to have an entrance that also fits into
that theme and now what does that theme
you might want to ask well I've actually
got quite a bit of this laid out already
I want to start off with a German theme
or at least more specifically it's going
to be Bavarian ich but it's also going
to be a little bit vague I do want to
keep my options open a bit and I guess I
could call it a theme park German
because you're not going to find this
strict kind of theming in any kind of
real German village in the south of
Germany but it's the overall idea which
I like to go for supposedly this would
also be a small theme park somewhere in
the German countryside and since I want
this to be like a small realistic kind
of grown over time kind of theme park I
want to start with a core that has a
German theme that more or less holt has
all the basic facilities and basic rides
in a sort of compact layouts and then
the idea is that over time
the theme park just kind of grew and
added some more attractions and other
areas and so I want to move into a touch
area and a Scandinavian area at some
point later during the series and those
are basically the three areas that I've
got more or less planned outs at the
moment I don't have that much planned
out though I do have a surprising amount
of things planned out already like the
different coasters and rights that are
going to have in the different sections
and a general park layouts so in that
sense it is going to be more blend outs
I would say and less winging its than I
usually would because I do want to focus
more on composition and park layouts and
making this entire thing come together
as a realistic park that could now
really be parts of like some sort of
real-life landscape and for that reason
I dunno just put some extra emphases and
give some extra attention to those
things that make it more realistic like
getting the right layouts in and kind of
planning your rides and everything
beforehand also I do want to restrict
myself with a couple of things during
this build like I want to limit my
budgets not make things too expensive
because obviously this kind of park
wouldn't have that much money to spend
and I also want to make sure that I keep
it within a certain amount of land so at
some points during this episode I am
pretty sure though I didn't film it I
decided to draw some borders around the
land and make those pretty tight as well
just to force myself to work within the
pretty tight strip of land that I have
for this park and it also kind of has a
bit of a square edge square-ish and edge
shape to it
that it could just be built anywhere
near a town or in the middle of some
farm fields in any kind of rural area in
Germany and that's well the idea of how
I wanted to layout the park I may even
make a parking lots outside here just to
give it that extra touch of realism but
not entirely sure if I'll really get
into things like that can be quite
time-consuming and I haven't really
tried it before but if I do such things
there might very definitely be some
things that I won't record in time
lapses and just
doing streams and things like that just
because I figured lately I found that
quite a bit of fun and I don't record
too many time lapses while I'm streaming
just because talking at the same time
while you're playing a game just makes
it a lot harder and a lot slower with
reading the chat and everything as well
so I do wanna you know stream some
things which might not end up in the
time lapses just so you know but yeah
anyway about this entrance itself it's a
pretty simple building as you can see
what's interesting about it is that it's
just a really small entrance it's
nothing like the big entrances of Disney
or universal that you would see it's
only got one ticket booth which is on
the right which I'm not 100% sure if I
want to keep just one ticket booth
because it is a little bit out of
proportion with the three turnstiles
that I have over here which is quite a
few for well me very small park that
it's going to be by the way I need to
give a shout out to Jake see for the
turnstiles designs because taking the
round pillar and putting the fences on
it as turnstiles was definitely not my
idea actually saw that in Jake C's let's
play by the way I can also definitely
recommend watching that let's play if
you're into you know more realistic
parks and a focus on more realism
instead of making very large scale parks
or focusing a lot on scenery his Let's
Plays are my favorite so far he's you
know real coaster enthusiasts and he has
all the details of coasters and laying
out their areas very neatly right and
his stuff is just really beautiful I can
definitely recommend it if you're into
you know the realistic side of things so
I put his turnstiles in there and had
the ticket booth on the right side there
just as the entrance doesn't have to be
anything interesting I may very well at
some point in the future though at a
sign on top of the roof on which I can
put the name of the park but
interestingly that's something which I
haven't talked about yet the park as of
like doing this commentary at the moment
has no name I am thinking about
something like germanica or German acum
or something along those lines the idea
is that the theme will be generally
Germanic not to be confused with German
it's kind of a theme based on the
general Germanic area where there's
Germanic people and Germanic languages
and I figured for that reason I could
get like all of the like scenery or all
of the countries around the North Sea
and so I could get some your German
architecture in there a Dutch part and a
Scandinavian part and that just seemed
like a good way to bundle those themes
together but I'm not entirely sure what
the name exactly for it is going to be I
might very well change that I'm always
open for suggestions by the way though I
never promised that I can take any of
these suggestions and actually use them
so I'm definitely open for it but please
also be open to be rejected because I
get many ideas and quite picky about the
names as well hence why I haven't
actually been able to choose one even
though I've already blend quite a lots
of this Park ahead already
now first thing that I wanted to do in
the park is make the entrance Plaza
behind the entrance though I won't get
to decorating it in this episode but
it's just so I could work on the general
area and have an idea of what I wanted
to do now I need I want I knew that at
this point here I wanted to have like a
small Plaza kind of square edge shape
with two roads sticking out one road
just kind of going straight ahead and
one to the rights where I can have more
of the German area at some point in the
future there isn't going to be like one
hub from which you can enter all the
areas because you know this Park wasn't
entirely planned beforehand
realistically so I can I didn't want to
divide it into areas that were built at
the same time so just sticking with the
German area for now but I did want to
have like a nice square to have an
entrance and have some buildings around
and have the main most important
facilities - so there's going to be a
restaurant which is this building right
here and some toilets maybe some of this
stuff that I'm gonna have around the
entrance but this is going to be like
it's more pretty important little Plaza
although it's not going to be anything
big and I do still have quite a good
amount of planters and trees around it
as well so hopefully in the end it
should look quite cosy instead of being
this low
I open square now this restaurant is
quite interesting because it's more or
less the first of the theme the first
proper building of the theme so it
should be a pretty good indication of
what the rest is going to look like I
wanted to go with the half-timbered
buildings which you very commonly find
in the lower parts of Germany there are
definitely many different kinds of
German architecture is really hard
almost to talk about one style but I
really wanted to try the new timber
architecture or at least the
half-timbered houses just because it's
for one it's a style that I really like
it's also one that I'm very familiar
with if you remember roller coastering 3
because some scenery days shyguys alpine
village was one of the most popular sets
out there for the game and there was a
lot of like stucco and timber frameworks
in there and it was very common kind of
scenery elements in many rollercoaster
country parks because of that so do have
some good experience with it but it's
also a style which I haven't really seen
much implant coaster before but I
actually do think it's very viable with
the different defenses and the balconies
that you can sink into buildings and
even the driftwood blanks which are
really good for getting those extra
winning details in or those wooden
crosses where you just want a smaller
part or a different texture so yeah I
think there's lots of different
opportunities to mess with when it comes
to the shape and texture of this
half-timbered stuff though there's
actually timber around all of the size
of this building which is going to make
it quite a bit unique for the rest of
the buildings I do want to focus on
having wooden details on the Front's but
not on the sides but this building is
pretty much has parts all around it so I
also wanted to have like framework going
all around it as well but the woodwork
is still an interesting topic that I
want to talk about a bit because it's
one of the points that I want to get to
in this series not specifically the
woodwork itself but just texturing in
general one of the things which I well
probably everybody at this point really
notice in planet coaster is that with
the same like limited amount of
decorations at the moment with
just a few kinds of textures like you
eventually just end up having everything
look the same at least in terms of
colors you just find a lot of repairing
and reappearing textures and even if you
mix them into different shapes and all
kinds of different themes like elvish
and fantasy and whatever you can think
of you you're still using these same
textures that you very commonly see and
it's one thing that's been bugging me
quite a bit and what I've been figuring
would be quite a nice thing to try with
this as well is to you know see how much
I can not just add a variety to the
textures but also use textures in a way
that you normally don't really see it so
for one example which is a pretty good
example I think I wanted to get a roof
which looks kind of like the Red King
gold roofs that you see around the
alpine areas or especially around you
know the German areas I guess you could
also just refer to the tiled roofs but
there isn't a way that I can actually
make this title so I figured I would
sing some doors into the roof and kind
of see how that works and I think it
actually makes a pretty decent shingle
roof if you do at least make sure to
kind of vary them a bit and place them
in a bit of a now like offset way every
now and then to create those offset
shingles I'm quite happy with how that
roof turnouts and same kind of goes for
the walls as well I wanted to have
stucco walls that have a really rough
sort of greyish texture to it it's not
entirely white doesn't look entirely
clean just has a bit of like older touch
to it and I think it's a pretty nice way
to get it in there by using the I'm not
even sure what it's called but like the
concrete's bottom piece that is meant
for like walls of I don't know Spanish
buildings or something like that but it
works quite well I think to make stuck
over there
but many different ways to do this that
I do in a try in the future just to get
slightly different textures for
different buildings like sinking
chimneys into buildings and sinking no
foundation pieces for any kind of
scenery objects into buildings to create
just slightly different textures for the
walls but I do want to watch out with
that a little bit because as you might
notice I am making very small buildings
here and
like cozy charming things instead very
large scenery objects but at the same
time this is quite a lag fest and these
buildings together probably have more
objects than the entire castle and LFM
even did even though they're very small
because I'm using all of these different
objects and sticking them into walls to
get the exact X's that I want and I want
to try to do that not too much and
that's why I kind of like this wall
because it's pretty flat but why I don't
know start sinking too many chimneys and
too many scenery objects into walls to
make new textures because then the faces
will definitely start stacking up and
one of the things that just create a lot
of lag in the game at the moment is the
fact that there are many objects that
you don't see because they're into walls
or into the ground just to create some
sort of detail but they are actually
getting rendered by the game so the roof
right now of this building is made out
of many different doors but you only see
one part of the door yet the entire door
is getting rendered and I do reckon I
might want to watch out with that
because this park may well lag a lot if
I don't start watching out at least a
little bit with the faces but then again
of course it's not something that I can
really avoid in this case because I
wanted to have this roof anyway to do
something and I do Nikki at least a
little bit efficient because well
working hard is one thing but working
smart is another thing altogether
overused quote probably anyway that is
just about it for today so thank you
guys for watching and hope to see you
guys next time in which I'll work on the
entrance Plaza over here and a bit more
as well